Build it.
Draw it.
Play it.
Vsauce!
Kevin here with some of the coolest creations
from extraordinary people.
This is BiDiPi.
Build it.
Valeriano Fatica carves fruits and vegetables
on his youtube channel, “Ortolano Production”.
Using a variety of knives and scrapers he
turns watermelons into unicorns, pumpkins
into the joker, and even uploads tutorials
for budding fruit carvers like how to turn
a lemon into a mouse.
Matthias Wandel is a prolific builder with
a remarkable YouTube channel focused on woodworking.
His videos tend to pair up with a more detailed
explanation on his website so you’ll be
building tiny boxes, a wasp sucking machine,
or even a wooden combination lock in no time.
This guy is the definition of build it.
teamLab built an interactive flower garden
that smells different depending on what time
of day it is and also moves as you move.
The Floating Garden has over 2,300 living
flowers that rise up in a circle around the
viewer, making them feel like they're at the
center of the garden at all times.
And it was built to evoke certain zen teachings
of interconnectedness.
Draw it.
Malaysian artist Hong Yi created a giant portrait
using 20,000 bags of tea.
It took two months to finish and depicts a
man preparing a famous type of tea called
teh tarik, which means pulled tea.
Hong Yi says she created the piece because
she wanted to recreate an everyday scene unique
to the culture of Malaysia.
Amy Shackleton is a painter who uses condiment
bottles instead of brushes.
By using a rotating canvas, water, and squeeze
bottles she paints colorful works that bring
together the rigid straight lines of a city
with the organic movements of nature.
And she hopes her paintings inspire conversations
about the cohabitation of humans and the environment.
And now for the work of Julia Dillon, a freelance
sci fi and fantasy artist from California.
Lorraine Loots has an ongoing series called
paintings for ants.
She plans to paint 100 miniature pictures
this year and picks her subject based on what
day of the week it is, like Microcosm Mondays,
or Free Fridays.
She’s auctioning off each painting on instagram
so if you know any ants that love art, let
them know.
Play it.
Ukulele Underground teaches you how to play
songs on the ukulele with the aid of live
performance and helpful animations.
Conspiracy is a group of multimedia artists
that create graphics demos.
Offscreen Colonies is an audiovisual exploration
of imagined worlds that they built to showcase
their abilities.
Finally, the music video for Fur Voice by
fantasia features a young girl experiencing
what may or may not be a dream.
Inspiration also comes from you.
Vsauce Creative Fan Showcase.
First up is Whereswilder with Bo - let’s
go!
Amin Amini is using kinect to improve the
mobility of Parkinson’s patients.
They’re using the motion capture to monitor
their symptoms and improve their mobility.
Carlos Navarro create Metronome: Your Animal
Metronome.
An app that’s a fun way to do music training
as you keep time with a meow, bark or quack.
Youniverous is a YouTube Channel by Zylok
hosted by an alien and their ideas of the
universe.
Here’s the band Harriet with their song
Irish Margaritas.
Kika creates abstract artwork driven by a
love of travel and nature using a combination
of non traditional materials and photography.
Submit your BiDiPis to BiDiPi@Vsauce.com or
share them with everyone on Twitter with hashtag
#BiDiPi.
If you need even more inspiration check out
Guy’s new show on WEsauce This World Of
Ours which is a laid back look at some of
the sweetest submissions from real Vsauce
fans.
So click here to go check that out right now
and as always - thanks for watching.